[Music]
first of all I'm not completely
convinced that we are going to WTO BRICS
it because I or any kind of Rex it I
still believe there's a fairly high
chance that it's not going to happen and
I think in a way it's high now under
Boris Johnson well that's doing that he
gets lifted than it is under Teresa may
because there's a sort of Nixon and
China effect if there's any if there's
any conservative politician who could
get away with complete reversal policy
both at a personal level which of course
Teresa may is completely incapable doing
but also politically it would be the man
who led the BRICS at campaign now he
wouldn't do this he wouldn't do this of
his own accord but in my view if if he
becomes Prime Minister he will do it on
the basis of de ma of demanding a no
deal Brett said because that's how he's
got to get elected by 125,000
Conservative Party members who are in no
way representative of the rest of the
population and who incidentally account
for 0.2 percent of the electorate so 0.2
percent of the electorate are going to
choose the prime minister who will then
rule over ninety-nine point eight of
their lecturers who has no say this will
be the first time that a prime minister
has been elected solely by a but by a
group of people who themselves do not
represent anybody who never had to stand
for election because your MPs of course
there are fewer MPs than there are
touring members but they have at least
been elected by their constituents and
therefore in theory represent the
country as a whole
but anyway so he'll get elected on the
basis of a No Deal brexit the moment
he's elected his chief priority is not
going to be to deliver brexit his chief
priority will be to remain Prime
Minister the reason he adopted the
position he did on brexit we all know
and it's Thomas including me know him
personally quite well because we were
journalists together the reason he
adopted that position was that he
calculated that that would maximize his
chances of eventually becoming leader of
the Conservative Party and it worked
surprisingly well considering that he
thought that he'd maximize his chances
by leading that campaign and then losing
he didn't expect to win it anyway it's
work so his his motivation up to now is
to become Prime Minister his motivation
from September onwards will be to remain
Prime Minister and I don't think he
would be able to remain Prime Minister
through a No Deal brexit he wouldn't be
able to get that through Parliament
without calling election he's not going
to call an election because that would
risk euro his lifelong ambition being
blown up immediately and therefore I
think it's quite likely that he will
have to compromise on some kind of
brexit deal which would then be subject
to a referendum and then that would be a
big question would a second referendum
actually reverse the results of the
first on that I don't have any I don't
have nearly the same level of confidence
but I think there would be a second
chance and I think that's quite
reasonable if we do go ahead with brexit
under Boris Johnson I think it is likely
to be closer to the note closer to the
WTO it will be with a deal but we very
much closer to the total rupture in
commercial relations with Europe than it
would have been under Teresa may for
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at AI TV
you